in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Paul
and Stephanie are with us hey guys how
are you awesome Dave welcome welcome
where you from - coma Washington very
fun cool and here to do a debt-free
scream all the way across the United
States also play how much have you paid
off we paid off one hundred and nine
thousand dollars in twenty three months
good for you excellent and your range of
income during that time we started at
about eighty and we're up to about a
hundred good what do you guys do for a
living I'm a project coordinator for an
electrical company mm-hmm and then I
work on a natural gas pipeline so I hang
gas meters on houses perfect cool and uh
what kind of debt was this hundred and
nine thousand nine thousand was student
loans for me
mm-hm and the other hundred thousand was
our house oh you pay off your house we
did you're too young dad paid for house
that's so completely weird I love it why
God how old are you guys I'm 27 and I'm
29
unbelievable Wow what is this house
worth about 220 unbelievable how long
have y'all been married a little over
two years oh my god so we actually paid
it off in November on Black Friday you
went to the only place that doesn't give
you a discount that day and paid out for
mortgage bank yes I love it all right so
maybe I'm trying to do the math you
$220,000 but what was it worth when you
bought it I bought it a year before we
got married and I paid 143 and I put 30
down so 113 was alone so you were
already rolling along then and he paid
off the 13,000 during the year that we
weren't married and then when we got
together there's 101 on the last two
years then after marriage so you've been
married two years and paid off the house
in two years and the student loan Wow
very cool Paul I mean you guys are so
whacked this is so weird how did you
know to do this you know your parents
must
Thompson my grandpa was actually awesome
with money he paid off his house when he
was 32 and so my parents weren't quite
as good as he was but they they started
doing the financial peace class and so I
sat in on those and I just always had it
from my young age I was good with money
and how many years ago did they go to
that class that was about eight years
ago okay so you're like a late teens
you're like 19 or 20 years old and you
go through the class with them when
they're going through and plus you
looked up to your grandpa yeah and he
was smart and you put the two so you're
a financial peace baby with a smart
grandpa yes all right and so he you guys
start dating and you're getting engaged
and Stephanie you find out you're
married to a weird guy yes or you're
about to be you know because you got
student loans you're kind of just normal
and he's got a house it's art he's
already tracking to pay it off and so
how did that discussion go down I want
to hear that I was actually nervous
about that conversation because you knew
how frugal mcdougal he was well not only
that he had the house but then he had
like a $30,000 paid for car at the time
too which was really cool and my car was
worth like three grand
yeah and so um it was I remember being
really difficult he asked me about like
if I had any debt and I didn't want to
tell him that I did I didn't want to lie
I knew things were going really well and
I wanted us to you know keep going in
our relationship you thought he would
dump you over the day I you know I
didn't think so but I didn't want him to
know I was embarrassed I know I know and
he's not obviously we got another five
no I remember like the moment he asked
like all do you have any debt and I was
like uh yeah yeah and then it gave your
cute look yeah and then I actually had
to add it up and I actually had about
fifteen thousand dollars total so at
that time he kind of told me about you
and my dad has listened to you on the
radio a little bit so I knew a little
bit but I didn't I didn't know like
their actual steps or anything I just
knew the name and so I downloaded the
audio book from the library
the Total Money Makeover and then I paid
off the rest of the student loans except
for the big one the nine thousand before
we got married and then we cashflow the
wedding and then did the rest and Dave
she was so great as soon as that moment
happened she was she was the nerd it
switched sorry he told me she took off
here we go here we go yeah what you made
you know you were okay yeah doesn't
matter if you have any debt it's the
fact that you're not going to stay in it
that's where I Matters out very good but
I mean you guys have got such a head
start I mean you're making $100,000
you're not even 30 years old and your
house is paid for your car you have a
payment in the world you are I mean is
your grandpa still living yes I bet he
is doing a jig yeah he got a nut he's
got to be just thrilled oh yeah they're
they're excited for us I'll bet a bet
and I bet he's done really well
financially and he has so you can he
retired at 40 and makes more on retire
yeah more in retirement than he did when
you're tired so he's doing okay yeah I
think he's doing all right so yeah you
can look out there in the future and go
that's us yeah way to go you guys way to
go so proud of you I know your family is
wow that's pretty impressive Gerry's fun
we've got a copy of Chris Hogan's book
for you well let me do let me stop
because I'm just I'm just babbling cuz
this is just so good ah what do you tell
people the key is I mean you got your
house paid off at 27 14 years old I
think it depends on where you're at but
uh first of all the budget you know
making sure you got the logistics and
understanding your budget and where your
money goes and then the sacrifice
knowing that you're delaying that
gratification but that it's going to be
better in the end and then just say
motivated through it what about your
stuffy um yeah I mean I for me the
hardest part or you know the key that
worked well for me was um just having
that determination to keep going there
were times when it was kind of just
where on you you know you get tired of
okay can you tell myself now you know to
all the little things and looking back
now though they're just little things I
can't even remember what they were
probably shoes or something I didn't
need you know but yeah I just staying
motivated and it really helps to watch
the show and to see the screams and just
keep going you guys um you have to look
around you at your friends in your same
age group and go wow we are actually on
the same page and hardly anybody is I
mean you you can't take for granted how
quickly you joined into this in your
relationship I mean one discussion while
dating and boom game on we're on the
same page I mean I the number one call I
get is how do I get my spouse on board
you know how do I get my spouse on board
you can't take that for granted because
that's that is such a because you set
this tone in your marriage that you guys
can do anything now because you can do
it together yeah and you learn to talk
through and work through and sacrifice
together to win and live like no one
else so later you can live and give like
no one else your you really have set
yourself up that's so impressive so very
impressive well done well done
love it love it love it alright we do
have a copy of Chris Hogan's book for
you retire inspired because that is the
next chapter in your story millionaires
and outrageous Lee giving along the way
very cool stuff Paul and Stephanie
Tacoma Washington
a hundred and nine thousand dollars paid
off in 23 months oh by the way that's
their house and everything making Wow
making 80 to 100 count it down let's
hear your debt free scream three two one
we're dead
[Applause]
[Music]
we're getting more and more and more of
these financial fish babies which means
more and more and more of you parents
are changing your family tree more and
more of you aren't doing it but then
your kid is coming along 25 27 years old
and you're you know you were changing
your family tree see that dad and mom
they put put him in the class with them
at 19 years old they're working their
system they're not perfect and that set
him up and the same thing with her her
dad's List in the show and set them up
and set them up because you can you can
break the cycle off of your legacy you
can change your family tree you can do
this you got this this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]